that's the pattern that's this that's
the secret to success did I upset you I
was pissed off the job of a coach on
camera is to transform that person right
now when people feel you actually care
it changes everything
fire is gonna be coming soon I promise
ladies and gentlemen what's up believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine I have
decided to blow up I've decided to get
my channel to ten million plus
subscribers I decided to be a household
name because I think that the believe
message needs to be spread more around
the world I'm taking you guys on my
journey and in this episode of my climb
the 10 million I sit down with Hank
Norman the media guru behind people like
Grant Cardone Mel Robbins and others and
we talk and we go deep in helping me
become a better on-air coach
hope you guys enjoy so ladies and
gentlemen mr. Hank Norman how you doing
man good how are you give us Wow good
I'm good man it's variances subdued Hank
Norman the fire is gonna be coming soon
I promise ladies and gentlemen
Hank quick quick intro like give the
audience a quick 30 seconds and what you
do I don't like saying I'm a brand
builder because that puts me in a
category with brand builders and I mean
I'm a coach I'm a confidence coach I'm
I'm I'm a person who helps you really
figure out who you are and what you do
and how to tell the audience and make
them feel your passion for your thing on
that that's it he turns people in the
stars want to be a star you go with Hank
Norman so I want to be a star and we've
worked on how long we work how long we
know each other that's a great question
a long time what's missing in my game
how do I get to my household name I want
to talk about before this isn't just me
coaching you I see us completely as
equals like 19-point 99.9% of the stuff
you're saying I was like he's a hundred
percent right he's a hundred percent
right I wish I was saying that Evan says
it's so like we're a lot alike in many
ways we do similar things for clients in
similar ways like we are a lot of
and so I think it's helpful and I'd love
to talk about and I think it would be
interesting some people understand that
you're so you're working to market media
Steve and I own to market media Steve so
as you said helping on the business side
and I'm more of a media coach like I
coached Mel Robbins from Z Canela done
zero media and now Mel's a big star
so I coach people and I like I like that
part and so you're doing this show to
show people your growth and your
transparency and I think the beginning
of that the beginning of our
relationship and how rocky it was or
whatever it was whatever your experience
was and I'll share what I can recall I
think is a big piece of it because in
getting cooking you reaching out and
getting coaching and having Steven me
coach you that is the first thing I
think almost everyone goes do there is
resistance there was tension there was
in you and between like whatever was
between us all so I had an tonight
changes that can you help me change as
clients do and people do I changed how I
communicate so that we could actually so
I could help you and I'm just interested
from your perspective what we never
talked about this what do you recall of
that time 70 years ago the tension
between this the reason you kind of
started talking to Steve more because
I'm sorry that that happened I hate it's
not uncommon for me like I people have
that I just did a Facebook post and
people are telling me how classes it was
like people might I get it my energy and
my approach things how it feels to I get
that and I'm trying to not have that be
a thing so I'm also interested this is
growth for me that's what I mean this
isn't just about stay in heaven like
safe hanging around sure okay so I was
on the cusp of my youtube career my best
video had a hundred thousand views in a
year and that was my best video and I
was super proud of it and I had just
come up with believe this is a Genest
it's like I was I just got with believe
as my one word and what I'm gonna build
my business around and then I coach you
inside this answer is oh can you yeah
yeah yeah for sure go for it for TV for
the
thing what I want and what I want having
watched your products in one of the
videos we're going to talk about you
coaching is I let the answer first then
I'll listen to this story okay
were you pissed off at me did you hate
me like what tell me what you felt and
then I'll listen then I'm ready to
receive the story I just want to know it
what what happened when you met do you
not like me you met it did I'd set you I
was pissed off I felt you were way off
way off in my information or way off in
how I was talking to you or typing to
you both and I said it's gonna do it
anyway and then we'll just see
so now don't get to the context years
ago
you've changed radically that's a big
change to be in the media whatever it
has gone through from eight years ago
till today that's a huge piece of even
what we talked about today and refining
him receiving information whether it's
for me I mean obviously I maybe I wasn't
a trusted source so maybe you didn't
trust me for that information so and
that shift is super important you have
to have that you have to be will you
have to be in a place to receive
regardless of who's giving you that I
hate mom's coaching people because your
mom doesn't know what's best for your
Facebook page but if you seek out
someone who you respect is an expert in
their in their field then even if you
don't agree with them you gotta put
coaching is tough I get you this justice
piece and I love that you're in a
different space is super confronting
that piece is the biggest piece but I
think anyone will learn from this
journey you're on okay great now what we
want more story so yeah so I had a video
that I put out around believe that I had
an emotional attachment to I put a lot
of work into this video it was a
six-and-a-half minute video and I sent
it to you because you're in the industry
and I respected your opinion and I
wanted your feedback on how to make it
better and you said it was too long
basically you wanted a one-minute video
1/2 minute something super short and six
and
minutes was too long and I didn't agree
Roback wanted to be I want to release it
basically as it is then you went down
this path of like you don't understand
how the internet works and stuff like
that to me and then like okay is this
this guy doesn't get it so it's okay I'm
just gonna post it as it is it ended up
crushing and I think we're coming from
two different perspectives and that I'm
getting YouTube and the algorithm and
how to win on YouTube when you're
talking communications and and the best
is like how to actually make those two
fit together
and we're both what makes this an
interesting matter different
perspectives exactly for me it was
buried a long time ago because you wrote
you wrote some email to me where you you
said that was like the most egregious
error of my career or something and that
was it for me I got even better
it didn't bother me and then you know I
followed you on Twitter and shared some
your stuff and we go back and forth a
bit and I was pumped to do this series
with you as well me too and respect the
hell out of you and when you say that
now I mean that as a coach and for
clients that's what we do that the
initial onboarding is the boot camp we
put people through is that just get
clear and concise so the biggest piece
and we'll get into it even because that
this concept comes up in long form in
your coaching video that like I just
stopped and said give me the answer
first that's the training of a minute
two minute video you got it like you can
make 60 long a video is at all but being
clear and concise and putting that and
having that opinion that lead line at
the top that is the media like telling
people I'm gonna tell you this until
it's it's English English class in high
school right right a sense it says what
you're gonna talk about write a
paragraph explaining that and then write
the same sentence recapitulate what you
said yes it's the same idea just in
video
you got a kitten with the opinion at the
top say it SETI which is what you do
actually you get all of this because
what I love about
the coaching video is you have that
little teaser open like you I know I'm
gonna get when I watch that that's what
that's what brings me into it it's that
same idea it's just the frequency every
time you start something in a longer
form it that's the pattern
that's this that's the secret to success
if I can get a tweak anything just like
I had you do before you we started this
conversation it's like give me the hook
hook me in so I know what's gonna happen
then I'll stick around for that thing I
think especially in the coaching videos
and the coaching sessions I don't do
that so I think that's really helpful I
think when my set videos I focus on
trying to do that of leading with a
powerful opinion and then totally
context and backing it up now maybe I'm
not doing as best as I could but that's
an intention Lee's going in yes he ones
I don't so right 100% it's glaringly
obvious except for your edits which you
edited to use that format to get me in
and then once you start that video yeah
you guys start bantering and it takes a
little while we can watch it or just
talk about American where I remember it
fairly well sure I don't have any
context for the other than your teaser
what I expected what I would want as a
viewer to make that better is I want
exactly what we just talked about I want
the encapsulated like what's gonna
happen I need that montage or I need you
to say I need him to say what does he
end up saying I does passion funny ask
you some question does passion fine you
or you want to play it or how do you
find your passion do you stumble into it
is there a way to find it yeah and so he
finally says that like for me I would
want something telling me like now I
know what this at least that piece of
the conversations about how do you find
passion so I wouldn't or can you stumble
upon passion I'd rather have it raised
as an opinion your answer yes or no
honestly would be my preference in that
because that again that's starting with
that lead now that's see that's the
takeaway mm-hmm click you're awesome you
have a lot of take away like your advice
is actionable your your you still other
people like I love you
and obviously a lot of people do the
more you team those things and bring
them into the Dyke particularly this
coaching it's finding a way to host it's
a finding away coaching on air is as I
wrote to you earlier today that's my
specialty like making now a great coach
on air was one of the hardest things
I've ever done okay
he was very resistant it's hard to do
what's the resistance that people have
to get better I'll give you the rule and
then we can talk about you and L or
anybody yeah the rule is and visuals
that's why I have to when you're sitting
across from somebody yeah and I get a
lot of experts doctors yoga instructors
any that's used to working with people
one-on-one that in a real man setting is
human that person and the advice is for
them and only for them the person you're
talking to
now you're coaching someone sitting in
the chair next to them that coach is not
for that person coaching for the person
watching okay so having that objective
view of this is no longer just about the
person sitting across from me this is
about the person watching us now you
actually have to deliver for them and
what Mel didn't want to do and what note
is life doing was like Mel you have to
break this person down like this person
isn't just here for my entertainment you
do have to fix them and they do have
moves from here to here the job is
actually fix them to change their
perspective to get them to see different
to get them to actually do different in
the moment here's all the rules you're
supposed to be changing that in that X
amount of time you're sitting down with
that dude he has to change that's a
story the media relies on the
undercurrent that is all media movies -
anything is stories but is Joseph
Campbell information there's got to be a
point of tension there's got to be a
point of resolution you got to tell a
story and the story is that person's
transformation I'm not only going to be
entertained I'm going to learn how to do
it you're teaching me and entertaining
me and the entertainment in the media is
more important than the information and
why do you think that that is not as
relevant if the cameras weren't on like
would you still not have to break
somebody down would you still not want
to have store
because in most experts daily lives like
working with shrinks is horrible for me
working with doctors is the shrinks are
really hard people that their job is to
just get you to uncover things slowly
and they want to see you on a recurring
me but they want to see you for a year I
know what an immediately wants that
person in and out in ten minutes I want
to be I want you to be done in ten
minutes
is all this training so as a coach
though that's what you want anyway right
like Hank Norman the coach you don't
want to sit with me for four five years
and slowly get stuff out so I'm trying
to understand hey in the coach how is
Hank Norman the coach on air different
than Hank knowing the coach off air I'm
not personally that different in person
that I am on air but the show I do on my
Facebook page the media Mentalist is
just the version that I want people to
see that sometimes does take me weeks or
months to get to the thing we he when I
went through this I guess so breaking
someone down to get them to actually
being a meeting star where coaches for
them and sometimes that takes months for
a person to similar to our conversation
about you and me in the beginning being
resistant unders I was just miss
communicating I was communicating that
those were ways for me to help you get
clear and concise and what that it
wasn't about blowing up the internet it
was about Evan becoming awesome and
sharp and people receiving his message
and what's different is I'm I've adopted
that style with people so I'm not all
that different but most people aren't
ever coaching's if you're a coach if
you're an expert in working with people
one on one you're never thinking about
what that looks like the third parties
so you you've not you've not adopted
this highlighted entertaining way to
coach I think it's more succinct I think
it's more beneficial to your brand even
without cameras learning to do anything
on camera is going to make you but your
life better your business better it's
gonna make everything better cuz now you
sit you'll get to sit in your own
audience you'll get to look
you and say I can do this better I can
be more efficient if now I see where the
resistance comes then I can overcome the
resistance
it's amazing tools for business growth
inside the bubble not even just about
the people watching and now entertain
they're gonna be so I'm the same but
most people are and the resistance is
they don't it doesn't feel right to them
this isn't what I know this isn't what I
do they did like you did in a different
form you like I don't do it that way and
I'm not listening to you I'm like okay
we're here to do things differently
that's the whole point where my head is
going maybe you're on the same path is
that that that actually is a better way
to coach not just it is but that's
actually how you should be coaching 100%
and you can't learn it without the media
or using the media the medium is sharp
media coaching coaching using the media
on camera and watching it and showing it
will make you a better coach because
you're in the back because you back you
know and you lose the people and people
like me someone will comment like I
honestly only made it halfway through
your coaching session because I was like
I can't
I'm sure yeah I get it because it's got
to be sharper great so so bring
sharpness in every conversation period
at every juncture when he asked you how
to do what your advice was or whatever
and you went into I have three things
and you started with a speech right I
was like dude I don't want a speech you
want the opinion make him do those
things right in that moment use the same
things you're gonna say don't speech
teach I don't want to hear it even then
teach yes so I don't know what your
answer was because I didn't stick around
or whatever passion you can find it you
won't find it doesn't matter whatever
your answer is the answer boom you're
never gonna find your passion by doing
nothing something whatever answer
opinion top now you go into your first
things like dude and you take that for
what was one of your points or your
first point in the thing do you remember
what your takeaway was or your first one
was your most important core values
what's your one word now you do
with him great do you want me to break
it down in advance or just show what's
happening you could but I personally
don't anything you need it I think you
go here's the first thing you need to do
what's so you're busy now you got to
keep me in and when I say me now in this
context I'm leaning on the single person
watching you which is the other tip
better this whole thing is just for that
one person watching you have a million
people watch the video we all only
consumed it one on one you got to know
only one one person's watching that
thing you go to this guy so what do you
what do you what do you do
because now I'm now producing him to say
things for me for the audience I'm
producing him to explain so everyone
understands where he's trapped so we can
all help him me as Evan and me as the
audience together can experience seeing
this guy talk about what's going on his
life so we can see how you help someone
pick their word because that's what I
want to get out of this conversation
that's what I want to get out of this
piece of this video in this coaching
video I'm watching Evan Carmichael and
this dude I want to know how to find my
word I don't want to hear a speech about
finding words I want to see it done so I
can do it okay so this one missing piece
I'm trying to understand he's gonna ask
me a question like do you just stumble
into your passion or can you find it
alright you want me to lead with
something like you can absolutely find
it and I'm gonna show you how to do it
so my me doing my version of you is you
you can stumble into your passion what
are you doing right now
today that lights you up and now he
starts talking about the thing you go
what's one word that describes how you
feel about that type of work you're
doing he's like that any like no here
and you we see you guys I see you doing
it now I go now I'm now I'm doing in my
head cuz now I'm like oh these guys are
doing it and it's fixing him that's
everything now I
is a fixer a healer a coach and I just
had the technique I'm doing as you guys
are doing it I'm like what lights me up
I got so how do I say that in a word if
you're not really modeling if you're not
actually doing it the job of a coach on
camera is to transform that person right
there and right now take action in that
moment and get them to do it everything
I mean with Mel it was awesome Sun was
like I have a problem with my life like
what's your wife's number we get on the
phone with those we met what I did a
radio show much like this every single
day on am and it's like anybody I
haven't probably my husband get him on
the run let's do this your problem your
wife your husband game online do it
right now it's not just entertaining
it's the fix yeah no one's actually
fixing in the moment that's the big fix
to coaching coach fix it I love it
the education of the breakdown comes
after or is necessary at all
yeah yeah oh yeah we're gonna go so we
go through the process I don't even say
we're gonna go through a process I just
lead them through it yeah we get a
result I'm at the end I say here's what
we did a result was a lot inside the
result piece so overall what I'm wanting
to see is what I want now that zoom out
many layers you know I need at the top
before that first question or sometime
now because I don't really care about
the will be I don't care about the order
but these things have to happen I have
to know how he feels really stuck I knew
the story of knowing where he is right
now
so that at the end of this show I see
him I see the transformation I feel it I
know he's fixed without the beginning
story
I don't recognize an end so I need I
need where he's stuck and you see and I
don't need words this is where dudes get
it wrong every time if you do to like so
what's wrong with he's like I don't not
make it enough money
okay let's fix that No how is your life
huh because you don't have enough money
what's really going on for you
emotionally what's the story
that's what's the facts what's the story
and when you get that story out of this
guy it's rather that I wouldn't have
allowed this guy to go
can you just fall into the you're not
running my show shut up this isn't your
show they ask questions I ask questions
second of all you're here for a reason
dude because you're stuck somewhere
ready is stuck and how does that make
you feel because until that person taps
into how they are they're not gonna fix
it what we get busy doing in our lives
when we're stuck is we don't change
because we're don't allow ourselves to
access that pain we pretend like it's
not a big deal you're you're taking it
as your responsibility heaven which is
why you're in the next level person
because you're taking is your
responsibility to rip those bandages off
and go in that's everything that's it
yeah there's always a reason behind why
they're coming in besides what they lead
with always which is why I love the one
on one one thing there's nothing but my
coaching fuse okay I'm giving you three
or four or five compliments and you just
it's it's hard to give you compliments
because you either don't like accepting
them and you don't accept them or you
don't feel deserving or you it actually
kind it comes off smoggy to me okay and
I know I know you personally we hang out
together you're a nice guy and you're
warm like I want to feel that baby's
real for you is these little tiny things
that's gonna make you what's gonna make
videos more successful is the more
relatable you get as a human being to
the audience okay do you agree
relatable yes I'm definitely open to it
complements for me what I want to be
told that I suck like I think I'm great
already so so I want to hear why I suck
and how to get better especially when
doing something like this
let's talk about that for a second look
yep that idea I get I had totally
understand it's not media-friendly
cuz nobody's like that I don't want to
hear I suck I don't want to watch a dude
that wants to hear he sucks I want to
watch a human being it's a person that
has trouble taking criticism a little
bitter it stings and he admits where it
stings and then when he gets compliments
it's nice or embarrassing it's a it's
human it's emotional it's feeling you're
you've chopped off the feelings on both
ends and we're in the business rounding
a discussion of selling emotional impact
people you have the facts dude all we're
really working on right now this show
and the only everything we talk about in
detail is how to make you more access
more emotion how to care how to show me
you care about that guy and presented in
an edible way for an audience and in
digestible pieces how do I work on that
I think that comes out best when I'm
angry at somebody and then we work
through it and the love that I have for
them actually ends up carrying them
through because I'll sit with somebody
and show them more love than anybody in
their life you still give them the
answer that's a hard push forward that's
when it shows itself best if somebody's
sitting there saying Evan I love your
videos thank you so much you changed my
life it's like thank you I appreciate it
probably isn't make them feel the
greatest I understand what you're saying
so what's my to do what's my homework on
that so to do is interesting for you as
it has been for me we kind of I don't
lack empathy it's just I cut it off or
yeah because of my insecurities and how
I was raised and I I don't receive
compliments well I in there so it's it's
not a topic I'm talking about as if I'm
just a coach it's it's been a huge part
of my life what I do what I've done is
because I know someone's watching this I
open up I slow down I open up like I
really go in with a conscious intention
of being like I'm gonna connect to this
person I mean like saying that that's
what I changed because
I know the cameras recording and I know
someone's watching it I know this is a
bigger thing than just how I normally
would interact or coach somebody I allow
for allow for that this connection I er
I changed I'm a more receiving of light
and love and kindness and also
unfortunately the reason I shut down as
a child and was shut down as an adult is
i'm also protecting myself from the
negativity from backlash so the more
i've opened up as a coach and on camera
I also now find when people say things
negative about me it does it stings more
like things never used to bother me and
now they do because I'm a I'm opening up
on both sides in love and in paint and
in receiving but you know I you should
never take anything we never listen to
anyone criticizing and so going into
that interview that coaching session
with that guy I would tell you to okay
stop don't be presenting it's not it's
not exactly like and it is not hosting a
show you're not a host you're there to
make it you have to shift your entire
intention really concentrate on how to
get connected to that person and and
open them up get him to trust you so
much it he's gonna spill all the beans
cry lay it on the table and say this is
what is the most thing in my life ever
and you've got it help me please and you
receive that you're like oh man you
reach over you touch them and you say
thank you for telling me that that's a
the thing that's holding you back this
is that top thank you for trusting with
this information like I never talk that
way but now you know with a daughter
like my ego has helped me as a coach
because she's it was an innocent and a
toddler and a child it's like huh that's
code that's on here come King be firm
but also be loving that's a coach all
right well it's on my awareness so it's
easy it's it's good to catch it I'm also
working with tests the clinical
psychologist is something I could bring
up with her for some practice and
exercise too I think there's some that I
lean in very well and others that I
don't so
do you know where that is or where that
shows up for you you asking why why that
why that shows or what you know like
compliments I've I've never been I don't
I'm I'm so focused on getting better
that I don't care about the compliments
when I hit a million subscribers I
didn't care about celebrating my
audience want to celebrate so hey we're
gonna okay we'll do a celebration
because they want to but for me it
doesn't doesn't mean anything like it's
great your milestone but push let's go
let's keep going forward yeah are you
resistant to connection are you just
streamlined so you're not doing it so
witness with my team I focus a lot on
making sure people feel recognized in
congratulating them and thanking them
and I follow everybody on my team on
social and when something happens I say
thank you or we get a great comment
comes in from my fans I'll send it off
to my teams they know that the work
they're doing is having an impact like I
think that connection is super important
and you do that because you feel it's
the right thing that they were you're
doing it because you know it's the right
thing to do I know that I could break
that apart what's the difference it
helped you and me answer whether you in
working with tests or us together right
in this moment or later when you watch
your video coaching video back in just
the parts we just talked about is
because then it's it's knowing whether
you're when you're sitting down with
somebody how to connect you may be the
type of person and you you are in many
ways as we all are it's like just tell
me what to do and then there's this
version that work for me with this which
is just fake it till you make it like do
those stay like talent literally telling
you to reach out and touch somebody I
tell it to a lot of people because they
put they're so scared to connect it
physically connect and having somebody
reach out and touch the person across
from them changes their dynamic when I
tell you that single action change
shifts everything it shifts crazy when
people see that he wouldn't feel when
people think he'll you actually care it
changes everything
so I ask that because I just wanted to
know where you were block like if
didn't exist for you that I would be way
more tangible take away to fake it to
you make it and get there but if you
really do understand and feel like you
like doing that then this is gonna this
this there's no cook very little
coaching involved then you just need to
get on camera coach and move into this
space that you love to do anyway which
is connecting be kind and and be
grateful and you don't need that much
tangible coaching the thing that comes
to mind is I've started hugging people
instead of handshakes a hug steve barri
york you worse I came in I went to the
Tony Robbins event just bejust after I
met you guys
yes time and I realized that Tony has
you break down like you're 16 needs and
I figured with the alarm how it comes up
but but love and significance we're
almost the exact same thing for me where
he has you break down how do you get
love and how do you get significance and
they were pretty much the same except
for what I do for my wife and son where
it's pure love but they're still even
then like I like feeling significant so
when I'm helping somebody when you when
you list down what do you love doing and
it's helping entrepreneurs and helping
them make a breakthrough it's love I
love it and it's also makes me feel
significant in doing it
and I wanted to try to break that
pattern of love just for love and so I
said okay what's it what's not just
thinking about it what's an action I can
do and I decided to do hugs over
handshakes and so people the Tony
Robbins event recognized me because of
the videos and all that stuff so
everybody who came up to me I said I
gave him a hug instead of a handshake
and people first thought it was a
germaphobe because I couldn't shake
their hand so that was fun and then I
was stumbling on my words like I don't
even know how to introduce that so one
guy I hugged and I said I love and that
was it so but it's still another thing
when people come in and want to shake my
hand
I'll ask hey can I give you a hug and
some people still don't want a hug it's
okay and I shake their hand I get it and
some someone like Steve I just make him
hug me anyway and just practice just
that practice I actually am very
feeling person when I took over my
business the the the dance business when
I bought it I brought on a whole new
team and I ended up taking on
everybody's problems so much that I had
to take stress pills for a week because
when somebody is in stress I I want to
help I have to help so I'm very
empathetic from a listening point of
view I guess but maybe not from an
expression point of view if that makes
sense it does so hug is a form I've been
touching people more through the
coaching process on their leg or on
their arm when I announced the kind of
hugs over handshakes thing I had
somebody say well you got to watch out
now because of me too and when we're not
gonna be happy with that it's like it's
it'll be okay
like I'm not we're not doing anything
crazy it's it's just a hug it's fine so
I'm very feeling on the receiving but
I'm not as much on the giving which
which could help I get how that could
help so I'm looking for okay if i how do
i how do we do it right now pushing
through it right now like here's Hank
given me wisdom I'm appreciative how do
i express that better so that you feel
my gratitude for the advice and the push
that you just did it and you know you do
like a little squinty thing with your
eye like okay you're visibly
uncomfortable which is cute which means
you're receiving it so unfortunately
part of me it's just being in that
moment and it's again you would let you
you shifted from the beginning where
you're like hosting hosting hosting to
now you're actually you you've relaxed
more into this moment between me and you
okay that's it you did it and then you
you showed it which is I think the
difference so now you've seen both for
you a hug initiates it and then I uses
then you're like oh it's working now
it's working for me and you actually
show you how you were feeling when you
look I think in this dudes we learned
not to do that and I had to look I had
to definitely had to learn to do that
just saying that even hinting at that
I'm doing that sounds like I shouldn't
be said I I have it makes me not feel
right like it's like this is I have to
admit that I I got I gotta show how I
feel that's weak yeah what was
interesting out of
out of our dinner was Steve had me write
down
I read that like hey we're gonna do a
show of you being weak or like what
you're afraid of and expressing what
you're afraid of
and then I like that night I love taking
action you give me homework I'll go do
homework and I made a list of the 25
things that first came to mind of when I
felt weak and I wrote back to see if I
could do this but it's not a it's not a
challenge I don't worry about being weak
I'm not afraid of being weak or being
vulnerable but expressing it could come
off as I don't know not care because
that's the challenge right in seeing you
say V but even in the video that I saw
recently where you set up this thing
where you laid out the parameters that's
the the challenges inside that which is
to say those things and show people that
even if it doesn't feel like a challenge
for you you understand that it is that's
what I need even if it's not indeed
knocking yeah you just saying here's my
challenge and I'm gonna confront all my
fears and I'm like oh this guy can't
just robot through right now I'm gonna
make my life better huh
that's confronting dude I'm scared to do
it I'm on the same path with my own my
brain but I'm actually scared to do it
the reason here's the reason I only come
to this recently I don't see that much
content out of me it's because I don't I
don't like looking at myself it's it's
frightening or scary or we like I don't
like it so what I'll do it and I teach
people to do it to blow up their brand
and are they why aren't you famous cuz I
am a lot of and I like seeing myself I
like hearing myself I have a lisp well
thank you for coming on even though you
don't want to be on um 50 years old dude
what am i doing that's getting just
dying I'm just coming at it from a
different angle and you are I'm just
like I got it why not do it now but none
that why not go that last foot well you
already spoke on stages with $10
like I'm done that was on TV every day
you and oxygen when I work different I
was on TV every single day for years
like I'm all the things people want to
do is like I'm not driven to do that
because I'm shy like I'd rather not knew
that and I'm shy because I fear somebody
saying something I fear judgment like
senior like but I'm like no I have to do
you have to deal with that for me and
for my business I have to well you've
been turning that man I like it it'll be
more for me because it's hard for me and
I also know how I coach people so I know
how hard it is for individuals but it's
hard it's super hard for me I hate it
I don't like fix on that now after this
in a degree the thing you're loving
doing I do not love what's that dealing
with my feelings and confronting my
fears I don't like up until now in my
life I've never thought any fear of
anything different story in my head I
hate this and your help like I love your
content cuz like that's exactly you give
me from because we're different we have
different perspectives so I'm like oh
but I just I do wish you did it more
this way like about it you're like I
need to be more like you and you need to
be more like me I'll get like a Hank
Evan mutant that's what we're doing
that's what this is that's the mash-up
yeah this isn't just me coaching you I
don't feel right about that like this is
this is us meeting in it I have great
respect for you and your brand and your
work ethic and I'm excited that you in
particularly in our relationship to your
entertain the idea of dating back in
where we had a weird spot in the
beginning and I I love you I love
working with you and I respect you I had
a guy tell an amazing story right here
you just you know you didn't receive it
in the moment dude ruined it doode I was
gonna tell you a really heartwarming
story
around I did one story I wanted a moment
where he turned away and you started
began again you speech rather than just
showed reception all right that's what
we're working on I appreciate you Hank
thank you for the loves joking I
appreciate I appreciate the honesty I
appreciate your openness I love your
content you're you're probably most
active on Twitter than anywhere else and
and you're always you're always posting
good stuff I wish you I wish you did
more you've always said that you've been
you you're the only person in my life
that actually encourages me to do more
what people don't know is not just
publicly you write me personal emails
you're like you should do more than that
like you've been very supportive dude
you're all right you're awesome
it's believed man but you plus somebody
else that they blow up and if they have
a great message that you can amplify and
spread and that's why I'm doing this why
hit 10 million it's easy for me to be
grateful and humble and happy and
satisfied that that's default for me
like it's it's I don't need compliments
which makes it difficult to I don't care
about complan so they don't need them I
feel great about myself I need to push
to do better so why I don't know about
yourself really yeah I think so I mean
either there I don't I personally don't
believe you okay then that's the whole
thing big test I would bring that up
with tests I think that goes way deeper
than us right here and now I don't think
I don't think you're being honest
emotionally for yourself it's either
nothing or it's everything because it's
a blind spot yes right it's nothing
that's the whole thing
correct I'm telling you I don't what I
don't love myself thanks anyways yeah I
think you say you have stories and words
to say how you don't need compliments
but you do sure of course that's what
you're gonna do
that's so you know I know it always
feels great to get accomplished err it's
amazing we just came out I don't need
them I know what
Wow I mean I want to get better I want
to do more I want to have a bigger reach
I want to spread the message think
people need people need what I have
learn to open up learn to take
compliments okay that's a self-esteem
issue so making that connection how is
it a self-esteem issue you say in live a
life of I don't need compliments as a
law is a barrier that has to go away how
do you tie that to self esteem yourself
love what's what's the connection that
I'm missing by losing that story and
saying I don't need them I don't want
them and saying you have to say it out
loud you just have to you know I don't
care what you say and I don't want to
really hear it I just want to see it I
want to see you do it I'm gonna feel you
do it on cash when you're working with
someone and they say something you're
like and I want to sort it I want to
feel you feel it that's how we feel
that's how this medium works
we have mirror neurons when I see
someone say why you crying because
they're crying that's how it works so
the brain works you have to do that dude
what we're talking about is this entire
exercise is literally to make Evan hoard
human how do you tie that back to self
love that's the connection I'm missing
cuz so self esteem is now you now say
I'm gonna accept people's love and
adulation and I feel worthy unworthy of
that but putting that wall open saying I
don't need that that's you that's
putting barriers up and saying I don't
need anyone else I don't need other
people I don't need human connection I
don't need that I need you so that's
missing for me like that look just the
way that that last few sentences I feel
like I need tons of people but you don't
act that way you really just said but if
you needed people then you would allow
the connection to be created which is a
complete connection you'd be nice to me
and I'd be nice to you and when I'm nice
to you I see you receive my love yeah I
don't I don't feel like I need people
emotionally well that's a problem dude
great I understand the perspective of
for people to connect with me and to me
to spread my message than me to be a
better coach seeing me receive the
message I can I'm the I'm there with you
yes
I'm not making the connection to
self-esteem
it's a you'll do it with tests you me it
just you if I don't if you don't need
something it's because you don't feel
worthy of that well I think I'm better
than you think I am that is superiority
and like an intellect and and a worker
yes does you have a crazy work ethic not
just that just just the work that I do
like I went to a YouTube event and I'm
I'm pounding myself super hard I'm like
I need to be do I want to do eight
videos a day not three I need to have
even better thumbnails even though my
thumbnails are yes this is exactly what
this shows this is where we're talking
right now in cocaine so then just let me
finish and you probably already have
your mindset but just for my own like
this is my show Hank listen up right
you're right but then they said hey up
and you're too hard on yourself like you
you you're doing a really great job like
you're crushing it you're you've grown
so much in the past year everybody's
using your your videos as demonstrations
of best practices
you should be easier on yourself I'm
like what are you talk I I think my
channel is errs have a Nobel Peace Prize
like I think I had the greatest channel
in the history of YouTube I do and I
suck like it's both so when somebody
tells me that they think I'm great is
awesome I receiving it for that for me
is more like I want to help them like
denying a gift is being selfish it's a
gift that you're get you're giving me a
gift saying hey Ivan you're awesome and
if I don't recognize that that I'm I'm
being selfish I'm not recognizing to get
them denying your gift but for me I
don't I don't I don't need it I think
I'm amazing I think my channel is
already insane not just because of work
ethic but I think it's I think my
channel is the best YouTube channel on
the planet but it's not well I think it
is but I think you're wrong I don't
think so of course your own because it's
not where you want it to be well I have
I think it can be way better I think you
can be a thousand times better
Rick in that's why it's not the best yet
I feel it's the best it's not well for
for some people it is for me it's good
it's it's amazing and it can be better
yeah it's fine I don't if you're just
trying to like poke me or something but
like no it's not fine the best in order
in order to start receiving an
understanding all these things on the
other side of that line doesn't make
sense I think the best can always get
better okay well that's not the best it
is the best yeah I was gonna say when I
was cutting you off was this is the
change you're not at your best yet it's
not because you're not at your best yet
a hundred percent I am not at my best
yet the channel is not at its best yet
it's nowhere close and it's the best
okay great again you you like fighting
over little but it's a weird thing to
fight over for it to hope to won acclaim
and keep i okay alright I give up but I
think it's silly to hold that I did
because I what I want you to see is in
you are on a journey to better yourself
so now you get to admit and feel the
full evils of a normal human being just
relatedness the relationship I want to
create with you by watching your awesome
material because you materials very
information dense which is awesome what
we're talking about here is the
personality piece people liking you and
following you because they like Evan
that requires letting them in saying I'm
not the best I'm not the best okay and
you don't have the best channel so yes
but I do have the best channel they're
both ok I don't think coaching wise and
you can keep coaching wise it's hard to
wrap your head around the ideas I'm
trying to hand you if you're gonna hold
onto your words because in letting that
go you know it'll makes you easy human
because it doesn't saying you the best
is weird and awful plus it's not even
true so it's even double weird and
you're making it's not true and you're
still trying to hold on to
one Drupal weird it's it's it's holding
on to two opposing thoughts at the same
time and I do that a lot that's weird
well that I'm weird but no yeah it's the
whole thing
it's a probability to hold on to to
competing thoughts at the same time and
get both of them the yin-yang is is the
entire thing sure but not in this not
yes
yin and yang is the answer to everything
it's the positive there's no positive
without the negative they have to come
together there's no balance
except in a real human being saying I'm
the best but I'm getting better
that's not human doesn't where you go
through the looking-glass
is when you enter human emotion where
emotion is so I'm with you on all of
that I need to get way better I need to
receive more I need to compliment more I
need to express more 100% I'm with you
down like I'm looking for exercises to
do
I appreciate you cutting me off and say
don't go into a story tell me thank you
I just said I love you and you just went
on i pre yes I need to get better the
disconnect that this all started from
was you said that you feel like I don't
have self esteem or self love and became
so I don't I don't understand that
connection because I feel like I'm great
and I need to get better so the
willingness to accept compliments isn't
because I feel like I'm better than
somebody else I feel like I don't I
don't I don't need the emotional support
not because I'm afraid of it I just
don't I don't feel like I need it I feel
like I love myself so it's either the
whole thing or it's nothing right
because it's such a blind spot then it's
the entire thing then like I actually
have zero love for myself zero and
breaking that down is the whole thing
because I feel like I love myself so
much and that's actually why I don't
need compliments and I don't need
emotional I'm not I'm not like I'm not
proud of it I don't walk around saying I
don't need your compliment you suck I'm
amazing like I don't feel that way so
maybe you do love yourself that much
which is interesting and crazy to me
because I don't know anyone doing that
but
that aside they there's still room for
you to be fearful of letting people in
a hundred percent like this like we're
not editing this stuff out right good
this is it this is going up like it's
great why why Steve and why why test a
clinical psychologist and all this is
like rip it out pull it apart and tell
me I'm an idiot
or here's where you suck and need to
improve right like that's the best
that's why we're doing this series and
hope my hope too is in that it also
encourages other people to then also be
more vulnerable in themselves and like
through watching me struggle through it
they get a little bit more permission to
go off into it for themselves
that's the only reason why I'm doing all
of this stuff I don't need to be famous
like Steve gets so pissed at me because
it's like the other people work with
they want to be famous I don't want to
be famous I've no means nothing to me
but if you want to impact more lives it
dude as soon as you start talking about
impact then I'm in that's fame I get it
that's why I'm doing this but it's not a
need for me to like have a statue built
people what's my legacy I don't care but
I have zero need for legacy like what am
i doing while I'm alive the trick to to
making me do anything if you can tie it
to impact somehow I mean oh that's I
have had to do the same thing for myself
and I avoid it for my own personal
reasons so I don't want fame or
connection for my own personal reasons
but I know I am doing this and on air
with you right now and in my life
showing up in order to because I know I
can really help other people and I do
like that and I like that for them and I
like that for me well we'll have tests
watching back this episode and see what
she thinks and the whole self-love
awesome give me some feedback well I
appreciate all of that I'm thinking now
like how do I get it I want to I want to
apply right like the time we speak next
month stuff better have happened by then
going back to the first thing about
coaching people and it's I interpret is
this is not just coaching on on air but
it's coaching anybody and it's every
conversation when I'm talking to my son
we're talking to my wife yes
lead lead with what I think I want to
get the formula down the Hank Norman
perfect discussion down B what I'm
hearing now is before leading with the
opinion I need to figure out what that
person stuck with and the why what's
going on emotionally what's the story
behind the story how it makes them feel
why is it so important I get that then I
do powerful opinion then I just start
working through it and break them down
set the stage you're bringing them
closer to that uncomfortable thing
that's blocking them but I just start
helping them instead of teaching them
yes zero teaching zero it's teaching in
action not in don't speech teach right
no speeches I'm just teaching and then
we want to see at the end that they are
not stuck anymore
yes what made them stuck we went through
it but I want to see is when you make
them see the thing that's got them stuck
is now if possible it's not always
possible depending on the person's
problem take action in the moment Thanks
right now right call the person you're
angry with pick the word that defines
you that you're scared to say represents
you because you're fearful of not
achieving that goal do it now right I
love it
great I want I want them to feel unstuck
or at least momentum towards being
unstuck and you you've modeled for me
the viewer the path I need to take right
you're using me this conversation has to
be aware that this change your occurred
this is occurring in this person here
coaching is just for the person watching
and then after I've gotten the result
then we see them getting unstuck am I
saying here's what we did and give them
the template then there's viewing now
you're rounding out the show you're
closing the show for the coaching
session you knew you had to pick you
work you had to do and you you go about
you go you and you're awesome at this
the one two three the logistics of it
reason
that's not for this dumb person you just
spoke to their transform basically right
okay I got it
I know you know you're quick now we got
a practice now you got to do it so you
get to do a new coaching session we can
whatever yeah cool man I appreciate it
thanks Eddie
the structure is really helpful and and
thank you for sticking through it and
the frustrations I know you get it
endless and I know that I'm also a way
more interesting and fun client to work
with than some others but I appreciate
you sticking with it and the and the
care thank you
cool people want to find you where they
going
as you say Hank Norman on Twitter is
where I'm the most active but you know
I'm everywhere well not a link to the
scription you guys can go check it out
though all right guys you know how much
I love taking immediate action I took
hands advice and applied it to the very
first person that I brought on to a
coaching call with me today on instagram
live I tried to apply the techniques I
think it did a decent job but I would
love to get your feedback on it because
I'm gonna show Hank and hopefully make
him proud here it is when did you feel
most worthless as a human being man the
last three years of my life I was living
by myself I was using a lot of cocaine I
was drinking a lot I was gambling I was
smoking and I was just going in no
direction at all and so I just made a
decision that I was gonna move to Poland
and since I made that one decision my
life has just continued to evolve I've
always wanted more and and I did a
speaking course last year man it just
opened my mind and and obviously
stopping the alcohol and the drugs and
that made me realize how powerful I was
as a human to believe in myself that I
can achieve whatever I put my mind to
and whatever I want I decided that I was
going to take charge of my life and I
was going to go out and create something
by myself you know I've designed my own
online course which I'm promoting
through Facebook and you know I know how
I changed my life last year and I want
to help others close your eyes
just try to think of Luke from six years
ago who is relying on your brother
you're relying on him you think he's
gonna take you to the promised land I'm
just gonna give my money to him he's
gonna take care of me just that feeling
of you're not good enough and you need
the people around you feel that Luke be
that Luke again you're not Luke 2.0 2019
you're Luke twenty thirteen now I want
an emotional message from Luke 2019 to
2013 Luke what do you want to tell 2013
Luke Bryan good enough man you don't
need to worry about what other people
think of you or that you're not you're
not enough for yourself or that you're
not confident enough or that you don't
love yourself and then you don't believe
you so if you need to stand up for
yourself and and wake god because you're
enough and these 2019 Luke loves you
Brian you're amazing and what happens if
I don't change my brother's gonna take
care of me
now that's something way life goes man
you gotta to show yourself Carol are not
the people you got to make it happen
he's my brother he's gonna look after me
I'm gonna give him I'm gonna give my
money he knows what he's doing
what do I care this is hard man I'm you
know my heart racing but this is the
game this is it and listen I don't know
I don't know twenty thirteen year old
Luke I'm just playing devil's advocate
but when you can learn to tap into the
thing that it means so much to you that
that person changes that's when you'll
actually meet the connection that they
will make the change the people who you
will help best are the ones who you've
been through the same thing as them
right I can't talk about drugs I've
never done drugs so don't talk to me
about how to get over drugs I can give
you general advice but like I'm not the
guy I don't have the same familiar
family pressures and all that but the
people who you want to reach are 2013
Luke and twenty thirteen year old Luke
doesn't want to hear from 2019 Luke and
you have to make him hear if I set the
2013 year old Luke hey Luke here's his
mind valley program that you should go
and learn how to be a
what's 2013 Luke gonna say I don't want
to do that yeah like I was in a
relationship with a tenured potatoman
who was 10 years older than me at that
time and she was pushing me to go just
to study into to be better and I was
only doing it because it was gonna make
her happy
great that's what you need to help so
how'd he break through that about 2013
Luke in the way that that girlfriend
couldn't that's the whole game right and
listen listen you don't have to have the
answer now like I'm pushing you because
that's the game when you figure that out
then your content starts to soar yeah I
got to relate to those to those people
you know I had a I had a 20 year old hit
him no no robbing today you know to
yourself you need to relate to the old
yourself the reason why I love helping
entrepreneurs so much is because when I
was 19 and I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I was making 300 bucks
a month and I told my business partner I
quit because I feel worthless as a human
being that's what I see in on 10 ebuddy
to have to feel that same pain that I
went through and it's real like I can go
back to that moment and see myself
crying my face off and stuff kind of my
nose on my eyes and my mom coming over
putting her hand on my shoulder and
saying something I have no idea what she
said because I was just lost as a human
lost felt absolutely worthless and so I
could I could tap into that and then it
makes it and makes the words important
but I want you to win so badly at this
and I have no idea who you are
we just met hi I'm Evan Wright that's
the game that's the game like when you
see somebody who is like you you need to
figure out how to make that connection
to them you need to break through to
2013 Luke or you don't win or you're
just sounding like everybody else so I
don't do that that's on You Man like you
got it that's why I was trying to get
you to channel like Channel 2013 you're
a loop like I would save this video play
it back and watch it or or do it again
yourself like I would do this this is
your speaker training every day until
you get it turn your phone on start
press
Kord close your eyes B 2013 Luke be the
Punk be the guy doesn't listen anybody
be the guy who was dating this girl
who's telling him to do something he
doesn't want to do it but this is what I
lose her so who's gonna do it
feel the guys just giving this money to
his brother it doesn't want to take
responsibility forget I've run away I'll
just take some cocaine like that's what
I'm gonna do
be that guy feel that guy and then he
pissed off at that guy and then jump to
2019 and like strangle him you need to
break through to 2013 Luke and then when
you do that your content is a different
story like your content now is amazing
people will watch her stop and say holy
cow this guy Luke like he's he connects
to me he speaks to me somehow I have no
I've never met this guy but he's
speaking like right to my soul I love
everything you're saying it's great but
again it sounds like everybody else and
so and I believe that you've got way
more than then what you put note now
it's great and you're on your journey
and you don't have to be perfect yet but
that's the training and then every day
you you close your eyes picture that
Luke and then you whatever you need to
do you need to scream at him you need to
hug him you need to love him
you need to have empathy you need to
have rage go through the emotions and
figure out what works and then when you
get it when you open your eyes said that
was it like I connected the 2013 Luke I
connected to him and then that's what
you tap into every time when you're
making your videos so when you're
telling me that I need to go live the
best version of my life great if you
just see the words is one thing but if
you're channeling twenty thirteen year
old Luke this is a whole different story
so do the work everyday like hang up now
and go practice that's the best you're
gonna get for me that's the best advice
like and you rock with that and then and
then everybody meet who has similar
issues as twenty thirteen year old Luke
and then how do you make your Instagram
content better that's what you picture
every time twenty thirteen year old Luke
and the message that he needs to hear
today so in in terms of that that's
that's what you're putting me is
targeting right but what about the rest
of the world if you're putting out fire
content like that
we'll come to you people will look at it
and they'll share it and they'll love it
and they'll say this guy speaking to me
now your style will be different and
that's okay so I go to the board
everybody write all of the people that
profile Eric Thomas you know Eric Thomas
yeah
Eric Thomas will yell his face off he'll
yell about everything like he's oh he's
always seems to be angry and like he'll
get you pumped up and motivated to do
anything you gotta go to the bathroom
you know get your sentence go to the
bathroom
that's Eric Thomas I love Eric Oprah
Winfrey is gonna hug you I'm gonna make
you cry I'm gonna listen to you but
Oprah and Eric have 98 percent the same
message it's the same as that you have
but your style will be different now not
everybody loves Oprah and not everybody
loves Eric that's okay
but you'll you'll find these people
people will come and find you and
Samantha this guy the way that he speaks
whether you saying it I know I've heard
it a thousand times with the way Luke
says it it just makes me do something
sounds will remote it's gonna come if
you can learn to connect with 2013 Luke
and actually get him to take that course
and love taking that course instead of
doing it for the older girlfriend that's
when you win bring that energy to all
your content video content every day
one-minute videos people will follow you
people you'll blow up I'm pumped to do a
top 10 on you one day man let's not make
it to man yeah man you've got it but
that's the exercise yeah and then when
you can when you watch your content when
you watch your close i video back and
then and you run through different
emotions of of yelling or hugging or
happy or crying or rage or whatever
you're cycling through when you feel it
but you should you should get emotional
feeling like holy cow Ajith we just did
it I did it that was it
and now because you've recorded it now
you see what it looks like like you may
have done the whole thing with your eyes
closed but you've recorded it so now you
see what you
look like when you've hit the moment
you've got a recording of it and so now
you can tap into it you're gonna get it
once and then and then you won't get it
again and it's learning to consistently
get there but yep you have the recording
and so you practice you get back to it
you practice that's the game man you
need to get twenty thirteen year old
Luke to do the work the heart be like oh
my god when I that's great that's gross
yeah man every day is unpredictable for
me and everything that I'm doing it's uh
he's mind blowing you know and to speak
to you as well it's something that you
know I've never even thought about so
I'm just pushing myself man I'm just
continuously growing and and I'm not
backing down you know there's no limit I
love it man
I'm cheering for you hard you need to
find a way to connect to 2013 Luke but
by the end of the next week practice
every day but you want to be you want to
be a world-class speaker that's the
assignment if you're practicing every
day you'll get there if you do it once a
month you won't yeah you know I mean I'm
on Easter every every day do my videos
every morning so and but not with this
not without intention it's easy to go on
Instagram say guys like go live a great
life you know do something that
challenges you it's important you don't
want to be in the same spot you are one
year from today like there's no emotion
the words are great but it's not the
right energy you have the right words
you have a great mission you just don't
have the right energy yet and the energy
you need is the one that will convince
2013 Luke to do something not because
it's being forced to but because he you
spark something in him and the light
bulb went off and he realized holy cow
that guy's right yeah that's deep man
practice dude so what do you think guys
gonna do a good job am I getting better
let me know put in the comments below
also if you want to see my session with
tests a psychologist check out their
video link right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there